desde la torre de londres
al oeste a los terrenos del castillo de
jardín
y hacia el norte en los muros de la
fortaleza de edimburgo estruendosos
estallidos resonaron de varios cañones
en todo el reino unido mientras líderes
militares honraron la muerte del ex
oficial naval y esposo de la reina
isabel el príncipe felipe se realizaron
41 disparos coordinados uno por cada
minuto desde el mediodía el saludo más
largo según el protocolo militar y
utilizado en el pasado para conmemorar
la muerte de la reina victoria y el
primer ministro winston churchill
eventos deportivos incluidos partidos de
fútbol de la premier league y la carrera
de caballos grannacional también se
estuvieron prolongados momentos de
silencio como parte de los homenajes
mundiales durante un período de duelo
nacional durante todo el sábado el
público británico continuó presentando
sus respetos frente al palacio de
buckingham y los castillos de windsor y
hughes pero me siento triste por la
reina me siento muy triste porque va a
estar sola después de todos estos años
es bastante tiempo estando casada con
una persona él ha sido una gran parte de
la familia real y creo que ella se
sentirá sola ley
el protocolo viene ensayado para la
muerte del duque cuyo nombre en código
es ford bridge incluye la convocatoria
de
parlamento el lunes es probable que sea
una reunión pequeña y privada despojada
de la grandeza de las ocasiones reales
tradicionales debido a las restricciones
de kobe 19 y también por la versión del
príncipe hacia la gente que hace
demasiado ruido